hello everyone and a special welcome to
all you otherworldly Spirits joining us
for a Halloween hootenanny harping on
all things ghostly witchy and spooky but
unlike most movies and TV shows you're
gonna watch during the Autumn months the
films we're focusing on today aren't
super gory or incredibly scary or evil
their beloved Family Classics they
happen to involve beings from beyond the
grave and from down below like way way
way down below I'm your host Mark
Ellison today on versus it's a battle
for your inner child Soul as Casper
takes on Hocus Pocus that's right
everyone's favorite ghost who's too
friendly to be busted is looking to
knock out the Sanderson sisters in a
five round slugfest that will take a
look back at just how these two films
found their way from the big screen into
our hearts and then back onto our
smaller screens and devices every year
around this time in one corner we have
Casper starring Christina Ricci Bill
Pullman and a small but memorable turn
by Devin Sawa Casper is a lovable ghoul
who yearns to just have a pal or maybe
something more anyway other corner it's
Hocus Pocus starring Sarah Jessica
Parker Bette Midler Kathy to Jimmy and a
small but memorable turn by a talking
cat this Trio of sisters are hell-bent
on evil but they're just so fun and
occasionally inept that I'm kind of
rooting for them it's a tough call right
do you pull for Undead witches from Hell
or teenagers I know which way I'm
leaning here's how we'll determine a
winner round one box office round two
Tomato Meter slash audience School round
three characters round four iconic
moments and then we'll do a Wild Card
round that could involve who's better at
flying does Casper fly or does he just
kind of float dramatically
[Music]
or maybe it's going to be which film has
the better cameos Casper has a strong
bathroom sequence on that note but Hocus
Pocus feature some legendary filmmakers
popping into the proceedings the reality
is that this is an alien Predator style
Showdown you remember the tagline of
that classic classic whoever wins we
lose well you don't lose you'll feel
like a winner after walking down memory
lane soaked in Nostalgia but I am
ultimately gonna have to declare One
winner here inevitably disappointing an
entire generation of Millennials I'm
sorry in advance is just a bunch of
Hocus Pocus all right sanderson's to
their Corner Casper he's so cute isn't
he I wouldn't mind if he was the one
haunting my house just don't wake the
dog okay the stage is set broomstick's
ready Let's Get It On
round one box office ah remember back in
the mid 90s when we all wind up around
the block in October to see these flicks
on their opening weekends in theaters
it's a trick question no you don't
because I believe neither one of these
films opened in the fall they were both
slam bang in the middle of the summer
movie season this was especially tough
sledding for Hocus Pocus because it
leans way more into the actual day of
Halloween than Casper does and HP had
way more to deal with than just a little
case of premature release ulation in
theaters on its opening weekend of July
16 1993 it was going up against some
Heavy Hitters at number one on its third
week of release was Tom Cruise sprinting
to and fro in The Firm on its way to
surpassing a 100 million dollar total
than we had in the line of fire at
number two starring Clint Eastwood not
the last time we'll hear that name today
and at number three it was uh some
dinosaur movie not the land before time
was it prehistory Jurassic Park that's
it still roaming the Cineplex with
dominance in its sixth week then we had
newcomer Hocus Pocus at number four
taking in a modest eight million dollars
on its way to an adjusted for inflation
92 million dollar take but the good news
is Hocus Pocus did beat out another
family film in theaters Free Willy
remember the iconic shot with the kid
and the Fist and the jump I never saw
the movie but I really hope Willie stuck
The Landing they did make a sequel so it
could go either way
Hocus Pocus is going to be resting on
that 92 million dollar number here
because it didn't get a prominent
worldwide release so it's gonna have to
rest on its domestic Laurels against
Casper which opened on May 26 1995 at
number one it grows 22 million dollars
here in the U.S topping the other debut
of a big film you may have heard of
Braveheart that legendary epic bout in
the three slot after Die Hard with a
Vengeance notched 19 million dollars in
its second week in theaters and the Die
Hard movies probably the one I saw at
Carmike Cinemas again that weekend
because it's so good y'all but none of
the baddies that John McLean ever
dispatched make for cute ghosts like
Casper that adorable marshmallow would
go on to rack up 211 million dollars
domestic and 282 million bucks across
the globe I will point out that Hocus
Pocus which just this year was blessed
with the sequel it's deserved forever I
mean remember Free Willy 2 came out like
right away and then we got more there's
the third one he fought Jaws it's a
franchise anyway Hocus Pocus has set
some impressive DVD and Blu-ray sales
records in the decade sense seeing a
huge bolster every October for the past
15 years people buy Casper as well but
the sandersons they sell at a
record-breaking clip but back in
Casper's Corner the dude made a hundred
million dollars domestically if we don't
adjust for inflation which still beats
out the 92 million dollars of Hocus
Pocus with inflation have you seen gas
prices back in 1993 you could buy a pack
of Cinemas and a six or a crystal Pepsi
for three pennies Casper gets the win in
round one and gets on the board early
one to nothing
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
round two Tomato Meter slash audience
score all right enough yapping about
dollars and cents let's get down to why
we're really talking about these two
movies almost 30 years after their
releases you still care about them
they're in your heart like Phil Collins
and Tarzan and they occupy your soul
because you at the candle that you
shouldn't have and now you might be a
mangy cat for all eternity so in a round
it will be based on how critics and
audiences felt about you back in the day
I'm expecting very high numbers from the
crowds that flock to the theaters but
critics are people too I'm living proof
and the challenge for these films will
be to please the Tomato Meter all the
way to a fresh rating I'm also going to
look at how the firm and die hard and
especially Free Willy stack up here I'm
not mad at the whale I sound like I'm
mad I love you big guy I'm rooting for
you Hocus Pocus had to go first last
round so let's toss Casper into the
captain's chair here this movie had a
bunch going for it Plum release date
familiar character star power of Plenty
but on the Tomato Meter he couldn't
quite hit fresh Town settling at 51
percent with critics consensus that says
a Meandering mindless family movie that
frequently resorts to special effects
and transparent sappiness that's okay
little buddy rub some dirt on it we knew
we'd have a tough time with the critics
Owen gleiberman called Casper a fairy
tale with the soul of a rerun that's a
rot review but Ann Cohen deemed it fresh
saying it's a funny and often poignant
film that's worth re-examining today hey
there's a smile all right Salem
Massachusetts you're up at bat and it's
more rottenness like you know when you
go trick-or-treating and you hit that
one house that gives you a pencil or a
toothbrush a toothbrush thanks for the
toiletries you know on my street we
actually had a dentist you know what
they gave out Sugar Babies
it's a pretty good business decision on
their part when you think about it
anywho Hocus Pocus is Way South afresh
at 39 I know you're angry I hear the
cries we have done an episode of my
podcast Rotten Tomatoes is wrong based
on this very transgression so we did our
part but the critics consensus says
harmlessly hokey yet never much more
than mediocre Hocus Pocus is a muddled
family-friendly effort that fails to
live up to the talents of its impressive
cast well hopefully the new Hocus Pocus
can stay lodged in fresh town but now we
head over to the audience score to see
how you the normies took to these two
Holiday Hits even though they weren't
released on the right holiday Hocus
Pocus has its Defenders and they nurture
that audience number all the way up to
71 percent and we have entered
freshville way to go Banks is in
Denison's all right Casper it's safe now
come on out and oh boy Casper's still
rotten with the audience 49 for that
little floating pillow come on what did
he never do to you was he lurking in the
bathroom too long he's going through
changes I'll talk to him okay so caspy
has the edge in terms of critics Hocus
Pocus is bigger and better with the
audience so while I sort this out of my
skull let's look at some other maybe
relevant Tomato Meter numbers Casper top
Die Hard with a Vengeance Braveheart and
Crimson Tide on its opening weekend but
on the TM it's a different Tale the
highest rated film according to the
Clamato meter is Crimson Tide at a
certified fresh 89 then Braveheart at 75
and Die Hard with a Vengeance is rotten
at 59 all right we're doing a podcast
episode on that too come on meanwhile
Hocus Pocus debuted at number four
leaping over a whale who's still making
me sort out my feelings Free Willy is
fresh at 71 and according to my sources
there's four of those suckers in
circulation one time Free Willy went to
Pirate's Cove not the mini golf course
in Williamsburg Virginia but if you go
to a place called Pirate's Cove at some
point the problem might be you the firm
is at 76 percent Jurassic Park is 92
percent and in the line of fire 96 wow
job well done Clint Renee a and creepy
Malkovich with a plastic gun those are
some impressive digits but so is the
leap that the witch is made from 39 with
critics to 71 with the audience it's the
only fresh rating of any film and actual
contention today so that comeback earns
the sanderson's their first victory of
the afternoon or evening doesn't really
matter when you're watching this they
win the round and we're tied one to one
round three characters here the gloves
come off and although Casper I don't
know if he can wear gloves he looks nice
and innocent he's going to be feisty
here because his film features more star
power than you can shake a broom at but
will it be enough to top the greatest
gaggle of sisters since The Pointer
Sisters call me Jesse Spano because I'm
so excited Bill Pullman plays the Dad a
role he can handle with a plum no matter
if he's fending off an extraterrestrial
Invasion or acting as a paranormal
therapist who gets an opportunity to
live in a reputed haunted house with his
daughter Kat played by Christina Ricci
Casper is super excited to have some
fresh blood around whipstaff Manor but
uncles happen we all have them and in
the case of Casper his relatives are
like him dead you got stretch stinky and
Fatso who's voiced by none other than
Brad Garrett hey I just worked with him
at his comedy club in Vegas great guy
hell of a voice trying to scare the new
folks out of the Mansion their Uncle
presence form Some solid comedic relief
and we quickly buy into Casper and cast
relationship despite it Crossing over
spiritual bounds Pullman also gets a
chance to Showcase his physical comedy
chops speaking of yucks Eric idle and
Kathy Moriarty are wonderful in
supporting roles as is Ben Stein
delivering lines as only he can but the
real selling point is the deceased and
the titular ghost ain't the only one Amy
brennaman Pops in as Amelia the late
wife of Bill Pullman's Dr James Harvey
and then we get Devin Sawa Casper was
voiced by Malachi Pearson but at the end
of the film for about 30 seconds or so a
generation felt tingles of Plenty when
the ghost appeared in heartthrob human
form looking remarkably like Devin Sawa
but if seeing that finale didn't get
your goat it might have been because
you're already well versed in hot dead
kids thanks to Thackery Banks and Hocus
Pocus it set the template for Casper
well as we only get to see Sean Murray
in the 1600s briefly before he gets to
live as a cap for the next 300 years so
the bad news is that you're going to be
eating a lot of fancy feasts for the
next few centuries the good news is you
have nine new lives and you get to
witness Babe Ruth pitching for the Red
Sox the kitty cat is voiced by a spot on
Jason Marsden other famous teens were
treated to in Hocus Pocus include Thora
Birch in between her all I want for
Christmas days and her American Beauty
Awakening fun fact Birch Richie and Sawa
were all in now and then together
remember that it's 33 of the Tomato
Meter but 82 with the audience that was
last round now we're talking about the
protagonist in Hocus Pocus Max played by
ombre Katz he's a California Kid
sentenced to move East to Salem where
you get seasons and I know it's tough
now but dude it's 93 so the Patriots are
going to be really good in like eight
years hopefully you'll get laid by then
so for three centuries I guarded the
house on All Hallows night when I knew
some Airhead virgin might light that
candle
nice going Airhead what the kid's a
virgin it's a major plot point and kind
of icky we'll get to that later for now
let's fly to the stars with the leading
ladies of one of the most iconic
Halloween movies released in July ever
the Sanderson sisters Bette Midler
shines as the leader of the pack
Winifred the alpha to the beta that is
Kathy and Jimmy's note perfect Mary who
can always smell when a kid is afoot
and the Omega who probably can't spell
that word is Sarah Jessica Parker's
Sarah she may be dim-witted but her
Antics make for such fertile comedic
ground and the interactions between the
three are the biggest reason why this is
a flick we all keep walking back to
every year but Casper has those cameos
we get a murderer's row of hits
including a bathroom scene featuring
Clint Eastwood Rodney Dangerfield and
the Crypt Keeper appearing in the mirror
plus Dan aykroyd's in the movie but
Hocus Pocus counters with a hilarious
sequence involving Penny and Gary
Marshall as a couple their siblings in
real life but come on we'll allow it
Gary plays a devil we need to say no to
that it's a tough call here in round
three but I lean towards Hocus Pocus
simply because the sisters are better
than the hype and the surrounding cast
holds their own with moments of
tenderness and comedy while our Trio of
lovable menacing witches are waiting in
the wings Hocus Pocus seizes round three
and takes the lead two to one
out just everybody
don't drink it shut up
[Music]
round four iconic moments there's a
reason that we're still yapping about
these flicks some 30 Halloweens later
they're both jam-packed with memorable
scenes sequences and scares that still
resonate with families today 30
Halloween's later do you have any idea
what the body count would be if Michael
Myers had 30 Halloweens to play with the
dude would have easily offed 100
citizens without even reaching his top
speed of 2.3 miles per hour a cheetah
he's not but Casper he is a ghost he's
very friendly and scares the hell out of
not Christina Ricci she was in The
Addams Family she can handle it but
Daddy Bill Pullman freaks the funky out
when he meets the boy ghost and it's
such a Charming way to ingratiate us
into this world where the adults may
have the phds and college degrees but
the kids are running the ship well them
and the spirits that are polluting the
house especially the ghoulish uncles
that breakfast scene is an all-timer
Casper's Elders eat more than William
Howard Taft had for his first meal of
the day and their poor nephew is charged
with cleaning up the mess which isn't
all that easy when you your see-through
but this sequence also highlights the
team that the nice ghost and Cat will be
as she stands up for the little dead
fella we're not rooting for the bullies
here but those uncles do have some
pretty funny scenes together
you'll have a lot of fun
but they're just fun Poppins from time
to time the Sanderson sisters are much
more integral to the proceedings of
Hocus Pocus they share some similarities
with Casper's undesirable family members
exemplifying a Pitch Perfect Chemistry
and fantastic comedic timing Sarah
Jessica Parker is repeating everything
Ad nauseam never gets old for me and
Winnie's interaction with a bus driver
is an all-timer that wouldn't take me in
the morning no I wouldn't so believe me
though party pooper
but the witches aren't the only folks
with palpable Connections in Hocus Pocus
the sibling rivalry between Max and
Danny feels very true to just about
every family going through growing pains
and when your kid's sister who's all of
what eight years old is the one giving
you good dating advice like take her to
the movies you know you might need to
step up your game especially because
you're a virgin which should be a good
thing right it's an odd theme that gets
Revisited frequently throughout Hocus
Pocus that this high school kid being a
virgin is holding him back from aren't
you supposed to wait a little bit I mean
not necessarily as long as your host did
today but be selective it's cool
children it's okay to wait but Billy the
butcher he's been waiting for hundreds
of years to tell off Winnie and when he
finally gets his chance he takes full
advantage winch
hell
I wanted centuries to say that poor
guy's mouth has been sewn shut and it's
just nice to hear Doug Jones say
anything or see him do stuff this guy is
a legend Abe Sapien Pan's Labyrinth the
fish thing from the shape of water it's
Doug freaking Jones how about all you
high school freshmen stop sleeping
around and pay attention to a legend of
modern Cinema what's evident upon
re-watching both of these Classics is
that they do have a strong emotional
component Hocus Pocus is a ton of fun
but you do genuinely feel for the
centuries-long point of Billy and
Thackery and we're rooting for Max to
have something go right but truth be
told it's much stronger in Casper seeing
this poor kid yearn to be alive or just
have a friend or just have his uncles
get off his case for a couple minutes
two scenes toward the end really get me
in this movie Bill Pullman's kind of
sort of death and getting to see his
wife one more time and all the career
validation that goes with that then we
have the kiss Casper turns into Tiger
Beat Hall of Famer Devin Sawa and plants
one right on cat's lips and that's as
far as it needs to go Salem
Massachusetts it's a sweet day new mod
to a wonderfully engaging climactic
sequence and it's just the right
combination of sweet with a tinge of
okay I can see these two I don't know
how to say this matriculating their
relationship together the movie does it
much better than an adult like me can
explain it worked when I was 14. in
contrast the finale kiss and Hocus Pocus
is nice but nothing more and really
anything that's not the tomfoolery of
the witches themselves is just icing on
an already scrumptious cake the I Put a
Spell on You performance is proof
positive that we're here primarily for
the Sanderson sisters and it still works
today but again I find myself leaning
ever so slightly towards Casper in this
round for the comedic Brilliance of the
side characters and the cameos that are
truly surprising and pay off how many
times nowadays do we have cameos ruined
for us months before the move even comes
out not with this one for the record the
best cameos in movie history include Sam
Kinison showing up in back to school and
David Letterman trying to sell a monkey
to fancy lad Chris Elliott in Cabin Boy
Does anyone remember one I'm talking
about
no we'll move on then you also may have
missed another terrific reason to go
back and check out Casper Father Guido
Sarducci so tell me you have experience
I have a quite a bit experience not you
know like exactly doing it but I've
studied it before Dan aykroyd's
ghostbusting efforts fail the heiress of
the house hires an exorcist which is Don
novello resurrecting a legendary
character from Saturday Night Live back
when they actually said the words and
not just the letters Casper wins a
crucial round four and now we're all
tied up two to two I don't remember the
ingredients I I I've got to have my book
and now it's time for the Wild Card
round Legacy it's only fitting that for
these two beloved holiday traditions the
deciding phase will be about your legacy
both films have passed the test of time
but which one stands taller or floats
higher Casper scores points right away
for successfully adapting an already
known quantity into a live-action format
for the very first time he debuted as a
cartoon way back in 1939 meaning he
looks fantastic for his age and that a
number of iterations likely tried and
failed to pull him onto the big screen
with human actors and when the movie
premiered in 1995 it marked the first
time that a lead character was a
three-dimensional CGI creation Roger
Rabbit walked so Casper could run we all
think about the dinosaurs in Jurassic
Park but they're only on screen for like
what six minutes Casper is in the shot
for around 40 minutes and the
translucent effect still looks great
today but can he do this
foreign
Hocus Pocus may not have been a
technological Revolution but it made up
for that in other areas it's a Halloween
comedy horror hybrid but it also put
three women on the poster and all the
marketing materials sure there were
witches but we fell for them nonetheless
and a genre dominated by Bad Dudes doing
heinous things the witches Blended a
Freddy Krueger sense of humor with
Jason's single-mindedness and the
leprechaun's penchant for mischief and
those DVD sales they Spike every October
so much so that in 2010 let me do some
quick math 17 years after Hocus Pocus
was released in theaters more than a
million DVD units were moved then in
2012 it hit a new high with over 2
million sold the Advent of Blu-ray
technology once again brought a monster
surge in traffic for the property and
even before DVDs were a thing ABC family
which is now freeform launched their 13
nights of Halloween programming Hocus
Pocus led the charge with over 8 million
sets of eyeballs watching it within a
week and as we know from reading all
that love and support finally has led to
a sequel Casper never got one which
would kind of be weird I defend that
choice where are we going in this world
is cat gonna ditch her new boy for
another dead guy let sleeping go Sly I
will point out that Casper did have a
couple prequels that went direct to
Media I think I'm being swayed towards
Hocus Pocus but the real quencher is one
that personally I'm not a huge fan of
adults during Halloween
my three favorite witches
are you broads a little old to be
trick-or-treating I know I know I'm in
the minority and I'm a weirdo because I
love scary movies but I'm not huge in
the holiday activities the hay rides the
theme park redesigns no thank you I
don't really want to get dressed up in a
costume and I'm only going to do so if
my niece or nephews demand it which they
do every year now you see when I was a
kid that's who Halloween was for but now
it's big business and it seems like my
contemporaries love getting nuts about
the costumes and Fanfare even more than
the Tykes and a big reason why could be
Hocus Pocus it's fun it's the right
amount of scare and spice and sweet and
even gets a curmudgeon like me to
consider how much fun it might be to
lean into this time of year when we saw
it when we were young it stays with you
now it reminds us for youthful
enthusiasm for celebrating with pumpkins
and candy and losing virginities and all
the good stuff October packs it Hocus
Pocus got all it could handle from
Casper the Friendly Ghost but in the end
the legacy of the sandersons continues
to soar high they win the Wild Card
round and thus Hocus Pocus takes them
match
[Music]
I know I'm a wet blanket come Halloween
time but I'm really gonna make an effort
this year my friend Eliza has a
wonderful costume party every year I
will take the kiddos trick-or-treating
our own producer here Christian said if
I nail this episode in one take he'd pay
for my ticket to Universal's Halloween
Horror Nights Count Me In they serve
beer right okay not the butter beer it's
cute and fun but I still need an
airplane bottle of rum remember this is
all just my opinion and who am I I'm
your host Mark Ellis and I'm taping my
new hour stand up comedy special in LA
on December 3rd so come on out and say
hi today's decisions were up to me now
it's your turn hit us up with your take
at Mark Ellis live and stay tuned right
here at Rotten Tomatoes for all the
latest in the world of Cinema streaming
TV and everything in between thanks for
watching versus you adults be careful on
Halloween night while those kiddos
running around and finally to quote a
great little sister I love you jerkface
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]